a paris une image vraiment surprenante
le célèbre canal saint-martin suit une
courbe et je rentre tous les mille ans à
pareille époque qu'il est mise avec
techniciens et dans l'avare on découvre
un assortiment de détritus ce plutôt
hétéroclite reportage de philippe duez
et jean louis goût sert pour les images
pur de jouvençon le canal saint martin
située entre l'asean et le parc de la
villette
quatre mille mètres cubes de vase et
d'objets plus ou moins vont devoir être
enlevé les parisiens sont certes
toujours un peu comme des charges en
pleine ville mais cette année en vie
dans le canal entre deux écluses sur cap
kilomètre et demi à tort on a retrouvé
mais ils la voient comme un prêt ni
cadavre comme il y a huit ans d'autre
part la y en avait deux heures quand la
berline paris a débloqué 25 millions de
francs pour cette opération nettoyage
mais aussi rénovation 12,8 m q de ciment
seront injectés pour qu'on se dit qu'on
est en chine si les parois
nous allons profiter de ce chômage du
canal saint martin pour moderniser les
dispositifs de manoeuvre de certaines
dès cette année spécifiquement nous
rencontrerons un travail nettement plus
importante qui ait consistera
la rénovation et le comportement des
voûtes du canal saint martin sous le
boulevard richard lenoir et les poissons
pendant trois mois ils seront ce avant
de retourner dans leur habitat quant à
l'atmosphère celle du canal saint martin
ce n'est pas vraiment celle de l'hôtel
du nord et son côté mauvais garçon
mais cela reste un des quartiers de
paris loire les petits ne serait pas
trop dépaysé